what's up guys and welcome to Hardy's
hobbies the Chinna where we discussed
the latest tech news and delve into the
newest tech products today we're taking
a look at yg food prices didn't fall
earlier and if nvidia and AMD work
together to artificially inflate GPU
prices just like the ramen companies did
but before we get into that make sure to
hit the subscribe button if you guys
would like to see more videos just like
this every day before we get into GPU
price-fixing
I think we should understand what
happened to Ram companies first of all
so in 2005 the United States and
European Union find the company's
samsung tidings and Infineon for the
practice of price-fixing between the
years of 1999 and 2002 samsung pleaded
guilty and they were forced to pay a
fine of 300 million dollars to the
United States meanwhile hynek's was
forced to pay 185 million and Infineon
was forced to pay 160 million dollars
and this is all just for the US ask for
the European Union in 2010 the European
Union forced those three companies as
well as Toshiba Hitoshi Mitsubishi and a
couple of other companies to each paid
331 million euros for their crime so as
you guys can see there were all massive
fines and the actually represents the
second largest antitrust fine in all of
the United States history so it really
is a big deal but what exactly is the
practice of price-fixing
so price-fixing is when multiple
competitors get together and they
artificially increase the prices for
example to accomplish this one they
could simply make the stock lower and so
there's less stock and the demand still
be the same so people have to pay higher
prices to get the product or take it's
just simply all over price of products
and if consumer would still be forced to
pay higher prices overall in the end
what's happening is by some means
companies get together and make
consumers pay more than what's necessary
for their products and since these
companies are who dominate the market
the consumers are forced to pay the
extra price
and so all the companies benefit as
their consumers expense so you would
think that they would learn after that
huge ordeal right well apparently not
so right now Samsung hynek's and micron
dominate the DRAM market by holding 96
percent of the market share and in 2014
in 2015 a dram sales weren't doing that
well and the price of DRAM will really
too low for these companies to really
make a lot of money so guess what they
did they price fixed so according to
this lawsuit these three companies got
together and started limiting the supply
of DRAM starting in the beginning of
2016 and going all the way through
February 1st of 2018 and here are some
numbers to put it all in perspective for
you guys so in June of 2016
g.skill ripjaws 530 200 megahertz 16
gigabyte ram costed $68 and 99 cents but
today that same kid cost 160 $9.99 on
top of this at its peak in January it
costed a whopping 200 and $2.99 so as
you guys can see therefore their actions
doubled even triple the price of dieren
the boom of smartphones GPU mining and
the building of new hyper scale data
centers only added to this issue and
help them make even more money for them
the priced manufacturer the ramp
probably didn't increase at all during
that period but their profit sure did
revenues for those companies doubled
between the quarter 1 of 2016 and the
third quarter of 2017 and on top of that
in 2017 alone their sales increased by
47% which is the largest in the last 30
years so as a result these companies may
be facing another set of massive fines
if it is true that they have been
price-fixing and there may be more
regulations to prevent this from
happening again well that's what the RAM
companies did but what Nvidia and AMD do
something similar to that well a couple
of years ago Nvidia and ATI who had
actually
by AMD had bit of an issue in December
of 2006 a class-action lawsuit was
actually filed against these two
companies for the crime of price fixing
the issue of escalated quite rapidly and
NVIDIA even offered to pay 112 thousand
and five hundred dollars to the original
plaintiffs to drop all charges and stop
pursuing the case furthermore they
offered to pay eight hundred and fifty
thousand dollars towards a 1.7 million
dollar fund that was you that could be
used to pay all the others who
subsequently signed up when the lawsuit
attained class-action status however
fortunately for ATI and NVIDIA the judge
reduced the scope of the case to only
cover GPUs that were sold and directly
by both companies and as you guys
already know India doesn't sell directly
to the consumer and so they're off the
hook and ati only had a small number of
sales directly through their websites so
both companies were able to get through
that ordeal without any issues and soon
after am the ended up buying ATI so why
do you guys think that Nvidia was
willing to pay so much money to drop the
case do you think that they have
something to hide or do you just simply
think they didn't want that much bad
publicity make sure to post down below
what you guys think so finally what
about now did AMD and NVIDIA get
together and price fix well in my
opinion I don't think that's what
happened and here's why if you look at
what AMD prices shot up and when a video
prices shot up there's actually quite a
big disparity in video prices only
started shooting up when it Tyrion
boomed at the beginning of this year
however AMD prices were quite inflated
since the summer of last year and if
they would did work together then their
prices should have been inflated at the
same time like what happened is Ram
companies but this disparity makes me
think that there was no coordination
between them and also price fixing is
not an overnight process it takes some
time and as a result I don't think AMD
and NVIDIA were expecting such a big GPU
boom to happen anyways I mean GPUs
aren't meant
be used for GPU mining in the first
place so I don't think that this high
demand was expected by either companies
so I don't really think that they
foresaw that anything like this is gonna
happen and as a result I don't believe
that they price fixed about a year ago
or something which is when they would
have had to done it if they did it at
all
finally I simply just don't think there
was any reason for AMD or Nvidia to
engage in price fixing for the RAM
companies the RAM prices are super low
and RAM sales weren't doing very well
however for these GPU companies GPU
sales were doing great and the prices
were very reasonable as well there was
also huge influx of PC gamers in the
last couple of years and has led to much
more GPU sales so I don't think AMD or
Nvidia had any real reason to engage in
such activities therefore I don't think
nvidia and AMD work together to
artificially increase prices because
there is such a disparity between when
their price increased I don't think they
could have forced saw a GPU mining boom
and finally there simply was no reason
for them to do this
could they have worked alone and shorted
their own supply of GPUs possibly but
that's a topic for another video so what
do you guys think do you doubt that
Nvidia and AMD price fixed or are you
sure that they did and if you think they
did then what do you think their
consequences should be make sure to post
that down in comments below because I do
read all my comments and I'm curious as
to what you guys think so make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
this video then make sure to drop a like
on it and make sure you hit the
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this every
day but until next time bye